welcome to your shrine there is guys
yeah welcome to myself
we know he just did 10 push-ups before
that picture oh sit back down over time
one of everybody left go here gonna meet
up with Darius guys the Washington
Redskins who I believe is one of the
funniest players on social media we're
gonna turn him into a roast master we're
roasting rivals who roasted teammates
he's gonna roast me but you know he's
not gonna roast the good people of State
Farm because they're sponsoring ditched
the playbook
but Darius everybody else fair game
let's get
I may have found it one of my favorite
social media accounts and it's yours
because you bring the honest truth all
the time no holds barred
you get tanga heat constantly and see
how food man kisses and I do not want
that to change
but I also want to refine it I want to
get your ability to roast people to a
Pro Bowl Hall of Fame level I have a
number of pictures that we need to go
through to make sure that your roasting
is time to go man are you ready I don't
know the perfect one to start with what
my list is put pants on you guys baby
boy yes all right I could just see AP
next time he's right who gets roasted
the most of the team right now pain
seems to rub why just Iran hey I would
never roast Iran he just do funny how is
he yeah large human kind of like the big
show
yeah big guy but a small ass here Warren
Sapp pads and build and they got a tiny
head all right what about this young
chap High School ask him look like he
just got accepted to walk on the College
hey man I'm not getting my checks thank
you this was a test if you tried to
roast him I was gonna stop you we were
gonna bleep the footage that's a master
roaster huh that's the man right there
yeah
in order to be really good at roasting
you need to be able to take it as well
as give it I think we should take a
picture right now just huge season just
say hey Twitter roast me see and we'll
come back to it later we'll see what we
get they let my smadi and I don't roast
it it is a good smile it was go it was
just very important all right so now I'm
gonna go with my guy my starting
quarterback Carson Wentz what would you
have said to him in high school if he
were roasting Carson Wentz get bagging
no era he's really proud of those
muscles though we know he just did 10
push I was a photo at picture what do
you think about his haircut I don't you
know oh my gosh let me say what they
here they all got the same hair
if your hair was longer to be just like
that do you think so I know so like Zack
and Cody we like on baked they just a
cowboy go sit back down over time
[Music]
Leighton van der ash Dallas Cowboys we
talked about that neck though
hey what was that guy that went to
borrow the black guy with the big neck
yes I think his name was just big neck
bender big neck or just big neck number
two
can we talk about that photo place a
playboy yeah looking like LL Cool he
just kind of guy that when he tries to
look cool it doesn't make someone look
funny yeah yeah Oren Rogers the Gila
Lake like somebody call him jefe
look at this face his face was so
perfect but you look like sunshine
remember too tight yeah he looks like
he's doing this constantly trying to
just keep it out of that yeah mist
untouchable even a saber of Belichick
would you roast Nick Saban yeah yeah
what would you say the next saving smile
for change
you just won championship I really want
to check and see how you got roasted on
Twitter are you ready to hear what
people had to say let's get
my first one looking like all the Phil
had a kid with Cooley okay that's one
thing dude have you ever gotten Uncle
Phil before no your whole life that is
the most accurate that is here I'm sorry
it was great he just say that's accurate
when your real head is as big as your
fat head
no that was it go over a sec I would -
he's a barber quote what you lookin for
then DG quote you know the Fed is on the
risk and logo the barber a say no more
fam like now now that well funny do you
feel prepared to roast everybody on the
Internet's for the rest of your life
yeah for sure you have now been
christened a master roaster who's first
[Music]
this is Josh Norman of the Washington
Redskins subscribe to bleacher report on
YouTube for more dish - playbook